welcome everybody hope uh everybody's
weekends are looking good um last
weekend before thanksgiving as a
reminder we're gonna be here monday
tuesday wednesday next week and we will
be off thursday and friday for the
thanksgiving holiday a few stories i
want to go over with you today you might
remember that the day after maybe it was
two days after
the elections in early november
um we learned that the 17 year old son
of the republican virginia
governor-elect glenn younkin tried to
vote two times two times he tried to
vote despite being over only 17 years
old well finally glenn younkin has been
asked about this and glenn younkin's
reaction
is to be upset
that the media is focused on what his
son did saying it's really no big deal
and
it's sort of unclear if sever 17 year
olds can vote no no it's not um so this
is glenn younkin's reaction he doesn't
like the fact that people care about the
fact that his son tried to vote
illegally
it was just it was silliness i think um
there was there's real confusion on
where a 17 year old can can vote or not
and so he he had had a friend who who
suggested that he might be able to vote
he went up and asked um i know my son
really was incredibly respectful young
man yeah and uh and he presented his id
and when they said he couldn't vote he
said okay and he went to school so i i
do i am a little bit frustrated that
it's become you know the media paid so
much attention to it it's my 17 year old
son and i really would like everybody to
leave my family alone yeah um so
let's see if we can break that down
first of all he tried it twice he tried
it twice not once so it's not just well
you know he just said hey would would
you let me vote and no oh well let me
try another place and see if they'll let
me vote there is no confusion about
whether 17 year olds can vote there's if
you you have to be 18 in order to vote
now there's one caveat it's not even a
caveat many people know about which is
if you will be 18 at the time of a
general election
in many i think it's in many states
maybe it's a federal rule
you can vote at 17 in the primary so
imagine i'm 17 year old david pakman at
the time of the primary but at the time
of the general i will be 18 i'd be
allowed to vote in a primary
even if he was confused
they clarified for it they clarified it
for him the first time he tried to vote
so then the second time was what what
are we supposed to believe about the
second time and of course guys
if glenn younkin's son could legally
vote
obviously he would know that and his dad
would be saying all of us are voting for
me obviously
maybe they would have even done it
together for the photo op opportunity
like the idea
that it wasn't discussed in the family
or it wouldn't have been if he was old
enough to vote i'm counting on your vote
son
are there 17 year olds in this country
that don't know that
i knew from age 7
that you have to be 18 to vote in the
united states if you surveyed 17 year
olds in high schools nationwide what
percentage do you think knows that you
have to be 18
to vote
it's very high number we have an
ignorant country in many ways but just
about every high schooler knows you've
got to be 18 to vote um and just imagine
for a second what right-wing media would
be doing if it was terry mcauliffe's 17
year old son or daughter who had tried
twice to vote in an election that their
dad was running and it's absolutely
outrageous
one of our sponsors is splendid spoon
now if you're like me i love planning my
meals out for the week but sometimes i
just run out of time to plan them for
every single day and splendid spoon
makes that whole process a lot easier
they deliver fresh delicious plant-based
meals right to your door ready to eat no
cooking no cleaning dishes saves you a
lot of time you can choose from over 50
hot and cold meal options there's
smoothies grain and noodle bowls soups
i'm a big soup guy many of you know that
i also really liked the vegan meatballs
with marinara noodles delicious
both i and splendid spoon believe
eating more plant-based is a great tool
for feeling good
for helping the environment the list
goes on i'm not vegan you all know that
i think but splendid spoon is really
great to just help me maximize the
proportion of plants in my diet splendid
spoon takes all of the work out of tasty
healthy plant-based meals and you'll
save 35 dollars when you go to
splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below